Just for a moment, focus on your breath.
In slowly, out slowly, in slowly, out.
The same pattern repeats within every one of us.
And consider your pulse.
The beat is built into the very fabric of our being.
Simply put, we are creatures of rhythm and repetition.
It's central to our experience, rhythm and repetition.
Rhythm and repetition.
On and in and on and out.
Pattern can be pleasure.
In language, rhythm and repetition are often used as the building blocks for poetry.
There's the rhythm of language, created by syllables and their emphasis, such as,...
..."So long as men can breathe or eyes can see."
And there's the repetition of language at multiple levels.
The repetition of letters,...
..."So long lives this and this gives life to thee,"...
...of sounds, "breathe," "see," "thee," and of words.
With so many uses, repetition is one of the poet's most malleable and reliable tools.
It can lift or lull the listener,...
...amplify or diminish the line,...
...unify or diversify ideas.
Ultimately, this is the poet's balancing act:...
...learning when to repeat and when to riff,...
...when to satisfy expectations and when to thwart them.
And in that balance, it may be enough to remember,...
...we all live in a world of wild variation...
...and carry with us our own breath and beat,...
...our own repetition wherever we go.